[Musik]
und jetzt das sollte schon mal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend das
war auch heute wieder verdammt heiß aber
die temperaturen also nicht das
hauptproblem das wir im moment haben das
problem ist die dürre und die fing schon
im winter an zu wenig schnee im frühjahr
zu wenig schnee schmelze insgesamt zu
wenig regen viel zu wenig regen in
diesem sommer wieder einmal das trifft
landwirtschaft und schifffahrt aber auch
die natur entlang der ausgetrocknete
flüsse auch pflanzen und tiere leiden
unter den geringen wasserständen und als
sei das nicht schon sorgen genug kommt
obendrauf noch die katastrophe in der
oder mit den massenhaften fischsterben
kathrin ittner berichtet dieser welt
hätte wohl so manchen angler glücklich
gemacht jetzt ist er eine gefahr für die
umwelt niemand weiß welche schadstoffe
in ihm stecken an 17 stellen entlang der
oder haben heute über 300 freiwillige
allein im landkreis märkisch-oderland
tote tiere aus dem wasser geholt und 20
tonnen stecken nun in abfall tüten große
fische kleine fische schnecken ja ganz
ganz trauriges bild weil die fische halt
wirklich schon entweder klein oder groß
sind und wirklich schon stark verwest
und bzw 16 öffnen baden kommen schon
hervor cowens regierung und behörden
stehen unter druck weil sie zu spät
reagiert haben der polnische
ministerpräsident entließ am
freitagabend den chef der wasserbehörde
und in leiter der umweltbehörde für eine
million zloty belohnung umgerechnet rund
210.000 euro auf die polnische polizei
auf hinweise
wir wollen die schuldigen finden und die
verursacher dieses umwelt verbrechens
bestrafen mit dem wir es hier
höchstwahrscheinlich zu tun haben
die freiwilligen helfer an der ote
wissen noch nicht ob die kadaver als
sondermüll entsorgt werden müssen die
todesursache ist nach wie vor ungeklärt
erhöhte salz werte wurden gemessen
weitere untersuchungen laufen die
polnische seite schloss am abend
quecksilber als ursache aus ich habe mit
meiner kollegin moskwa aus polen das
erste gespräch dazu gehabt werde die
fortführen wir haben auch besprochen
dass es eine gemeinsame experten
bewertung der situation
austausch der analyseergebnisse geben
soll und wir werden auf dem
deutsch-polnischen umweltrates in der
übernächsten woche die thematik mit
sicherheit vertiefen mecklenburg
vorpommern rechnet damit dass der
giftcocktail morgen des stettiner haff
erreichen könnte es soll weder geangelt
gefischt noch die fische gegessen werden
baden geht momentan auch nicht
vorsichtsmaßnahmen wir hoffen dass wir
möglichst nicht diese katastrophen
ähnliche zustände erleben müssen es gibt
jedoch eine art von verdünnungseffekt
aber wir müssen tatsächlich auch mit dem
schlimmsten rechnen welche substanzen
die tiere getötet haben kommende woche
rechnet das landeslabor
berlin-brandenburg mit ergebnissen
das attentat auf salman rushdie hat
weltweit entsetzen ausgelöst
wobei man sagen muss nicht überall auf
der welt die mullahs im iran feiern die
tat vor über 30 jahren hatte der
damalige iranische religionsführer
ayatollah khomeini mit einer fatwa zur
tötung des schriftstellers aufgerufen
danach hielt sich salman rushdie
jahrelang versteckt die regierung
großbritanniens half ihm und einem
schutzprogramm das schienen zwischen
alles lange her in seiner wahlheimat new
york bewegte er sich in den letzten
jahren ganz frei und nun diese bluttat
bei der er gestern lebensgefährlich
verletzt wurde brase beginnt seinen
bericht mit den chemischen reaktionen in
iran
ein bild von salman rushdie auf der
krankentrage darüber die schlagzeile der
teufel auf dem weg in die hölle irans
hardliner medien feiern das attentat als
gerechte strafe statt entsetzen
empfinden viele genugtuung
als ich die nachricht hörte war ich sehr
glücklich wer immer das getan hat ich
würde ihm am liebsten die hand küssen
es war wohl der 24-jährige hardy matar
aus new jersey der es getan hat sohn
libanesischer einwanderer zu seinen
motiven schweigt er sich aus gestern
abend attackierte er rutscht die bei
einer veranstaltung in new yorks auf
offener bühne mit einem messer die tat
wurde weltweit verurteilt
er sei ein opfer von hass und barbarei
geworden twitterte frankreichs präsident
makro sein kampf ist unser kampf er ist
universell mehr denn je stehen wir an
seiner seite
es war sein 1988 erschienenes buch die
satanischen verse das streng religiöse
muslime aufbrachte weil es seiner
meinung nach die ehre des propheten
verletze rief der iranische
religionsführer komani kurz darauf in
einer fatwa einem islamischen
rechtsgutachten alle muslime auf den
autoren zu töten jahrelang lebte der
britische schriftsteller mit
polizeischutz vor kurzem erst meinte er
nach 33 jahren der bedrohung habe sich
sein leben normalisiert erwähnte sich in
trügerischer sicherheit
rushdie kämpfte stets gegen intoleranz
und für rede- und meinungsfreiheit das
attentat fürchten viele können diesen
kampf zurückwerfen
es könnte jene zum schweigen bringen die
sonst frei geredet hätten das dürfen wir
nicht zulassen
wir müssen weiter unsere stimme erheben
noch ringen die ärzte im krankenhaus um
sein leben er wurde mehrfach operiert
wird künstlich beatmet noch ist zahlmann
hoch dies stimme nicht verstummt
der wahl stehenden ländern wie iran und
afghanistan ganze bevölkerungen unter
der fuchtel religiöser fanatiker ein
jahr ist es jetzt her dass die taliban
kabul zurückeroberten und amerikanern
europäern hals über kopf abziehen
unvergessen die bilder von verzweifelten
afghanen die sich an die räder und
flügel abheben oder flugzeuge klammern
die flehten nehmt uns mit lasst uns hier
nicht zurück
dass deutschland tausende afghanische
ortskräfte regelrecht im stich ließ war
besonders beschenkt mit die schärfste
kritik daran kam aus der bundeswehr
selbst von soldaten die sich für ihre
ehemaligen mitarbeitenden einsetzen wie
ist ihre lage heute - trotz berichtet
ihre beziehung zu deutschland
zwiespältig jahre lang haben sie als
übersetzer für die bundeswehr gearbeitet
doch nur auf umwegen schafften sie es
raus aus afghanistan
nun drehen ahmed nadia und team in
berlin einen film sprachrohr wollen sie
seien für die ortskräfte und angehörigen
die afghanistan noch nicht verlassen
konnten
wir wollen ihnen zeigen wir sind hier
für euch wir sind eure stimme und wir
bitten die verantwortlichen hier macht
das verfahren einfacher bringt diese
menschen hierher ohne zu viel bürokratie
sie filmen sich während bilder vom chaos
am flughafen kabul von vor einem jahr
sie erneut ergreifen nadia hat neun tage
dort ausgeharrt um wegzukommen
unverständlich für sie bis heute dass
sie nicht früher in sicherheit gebracht
wurden wie das herr die russin dieser
tag kann kommen dass regierung und lange
zusammenbrechen wir haben ihnen gesagt
dass wir in gefahr sein würden wir haben
die bundeswehr davon versucht zu
überzeugen aber sie haben uns nicht
gehört
auch auf dem ortskräfte kongress heute
in berlin filmen sie alle hier wollen
von der deutschen politik wissen wann
dürfen kollegen und familien nachkommen
groß waren die versprechen im wahlkampf
das verfahren zu erleichtern doch der
prozess er stockt es gibt streitpunkte
in der koalition da braucht man auch
nicht darüber hinwegsehen betrifft jetzt
nicht
nur die ortskräfte sondern auch das
aufnahmeprogramm für afghaninnen und
afghanen
das leider immer noch nicht umgesetzt
ist obwohl wir jetzt schon ein jahr bei
trainieren aber das versprechen bleibt
nadia interviewt den bundeswehrverband
der fordert zu beginn eines einsatzes
müsse klar sein wie man mit orts kräften
umgehen will wer zählt all sorts kraft
die bundeswehr dürfe nicht vertrauen
verspielen denn ohne ortskräfte kein
einsatz ohne die ortskräfte werde
einsatz in afghanistan für die
bundeswehr nicht über gewesen die
ortskräfte waren für uns sensoren
multiplikatoren übersetzer unterstützer
viele geschichten von zerrissenen
familien waren heute zu hören auf dem
ortskräfte kongress deutlich wurden hier
fehler angesprochen die gemacht wurden
vor einem jahr das stimmt ahmed und
nadia hoffnungsvoll hinzu
kommt dass der krieg in der ukraine nun
alles überlagert und das schicksal der
afghanen in den hintergrund gerückt hat
mit dem blicke die ukraine beginnen
jetzt die nachrichten heinz werden den
verschiedenen regionen der ukraine die
gefechte auch heute weiter gingen
konnten zwei weitere frachtschiffe mit
agrarprodukten aus dem süd ukrainischen
hafen chernomaz auslaufen die schiffe
sollen eine ladung von fast 15.000
tonnen in die türkei bringen nachdem ein
international vermitteltes abkommen für
solche transporte erreicht wurde haben
inzwischen 16 frachter die schwarzmeer
helfen der ukraine verlassen nach
türkischen angaben unter anderem mit
mais weizen und sonnenblumen produkten
berlin hat am 61 jahrestag des mauerbaus
der opfer an der innerdeutschen grenze
gedacht bei der zentralen gedenkfeier an
der bernauer straße legt die regierende
bürgermeisterin gefall an den kranz
nieder sie erinnerte auch an den 18
jährigen peter fechter einer von
mindestens 140 menschen die allein an
der berliner mauer durch das
ddr-grenzregime starben
in den usa hat das lange umstrittene und
nach langen verhandlungen reduzierte
klima und sozial paket von präsident
beiden jetzt endgültig grünes licht vom
parlament
nach dem senat stimmte auch das
repräsentantenhaus zu alle stimmen für
das gesetzespaket kam und dort von
demokraten die republikaner stimmten
geschlossen dagegen zentraler punkt sind
rund 70 370 milliarden dollar die über
zehn jahre in den klimaschutz fließen
sollen
der frühere deutsche bank co chef anshu
jain ist im alter von 59 jahren
gestorben
nach langer schwerer krankheit teilte
die deutsche bank mit anshu jain leitete
gemeinsam mit jürgen fitschen von
2012 bis 2015 die deutsche bank
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
67 16 20 28 36 superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie unter lotto
punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 6
die wetteraussichten morgen gibt es
einen mix aus viel sonne und einigen
wolken etwa in einem streifen von der
nordsee bis zum erzgebirge können sich
schauer und gewitter bilden die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 26 bis
34 grad am montag gibt es verbreitet
schauer und gewitter am dienstag scheint
wieder die sonne am mittwoch kommen im
westen neue schauer und gewitter auf mit
24 bis 34 grad bleibt es sehr warm
einerseits trocknen die flüsse aus
andererseits bringt der klimawandel auch
häufigere extremwetter mit sich mit
starkregen sowie im juli letzten jahres
im aartal die bilder und berichte über
diese flutkatastrophe haben bei vielen
menschen im osten schlimmste erinnerung
wach gerufen an das was sie vor 20
jahren erleben mussten die
jahrhundertflut an der elbe so sei es
zum beispiel in dresden aus dem august
sachsen war besonders betroffen in dem
bundesland allein starben damals 21
menschen und auch die zerstörungen
gewaltig damit sich das nicht wiederholt
wird in einem dorf bei meißen nun eine
kühne idee umgesetzt
mehr dazu von franziska wunderlich
gemächlich schlängelt sich die elbe
zwischen dresden und meißen durchs tal
doch peter marek kennt den fluss auch
anders diese idylle wird dann ja zu
einem reißenden strom
die wasserfläche vervielfacht sich man
hat also eine strömungsgeschwindigkeit
die man selbst merkt in der straße wenn
man das haus verlässt das haus aber
steht gut 700 meter entfernt vom fluss
in bockwitz einem dorf mit
tausendjähriger geschichte als die
mariks ende der 90er hier bauen scheint
glb weit weg bis sie 2002 ihre gesamte
untere etage flutet ebenso wie die der
nachbarn das halbe dorf die nieder seite
steht unter wasser 2003 stand man wieder
hören war so
dinge wie häuser ausräumen waren nicht
die option für die zukunft und die idee
war einfach was passiert wir bekommt
diese straßen diese häuser einfach auf
das niveau angehoben wie das letzte
hochwasser ebenso
hochwasserschutz in ganz neuen
dimensionen 24 häuser vom neubau bis zum
alten fachwerkhaus sollen technisch hoch
aufwendig hydraulisch angehoben werden
manche bis zu zwei metern ebenso
scheunen garagen und straßen aus einem
modell dass olaf lear von der kosmischer
stadtverwaltung in stundenlange
heimarbeit selbst bastelt wird ein
modell und forschungsprojekt an dem
beteiligen sich wissenschaftler denkmal
und umweltschützer aus ganz deutschland
wir reden über wirklich erhaltenswerte
gebäude
gebäudestrukturen und wir reden
natürlich auch über eigentum von
menschen das ist das was man ja auch
immer beachten muss aber gerade wenn es
um die gebäudesubstanz gibt dann ist es
doch denke ich mal in der im interesse
der menschheit so was so lange wie
möglich am leben zu erhalten
2009/10 liegen die ergebnisse auf dem
tisch um das dorf zu retten ist eine
haus hebung sinnvoll und machbar
die kosten werden weitgehend vom bund
getragen ende letzten jahres wurden
dafür rund zehn millionen euro bewilligt
noch müssen sieben eigentümer überzeugt
werden und auch die statischen
berechnungen brauchen zeit denn jedes
haus ist anders es gibt auch die
komplizierte variante an also tonnen
gewölbekeller abgefangen werden darüber
dass aus bruchstein geballte haus
bekommt eine neue bodenplatte wollten
platte keller alles zusammen wird dann
gemeinsam gehoben die pläne für das haus
der marek sind weniger kompliziert und
stehen bereits nicht einmal ausziehen
müssten sie während ihr haus angehoben
wird hoffentlich noch vor dem nächsten
hochwasser
das was uns gleich gehts weiter im
aktuellen sportstudio
gegen 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express und uns morgen wieder um
21.45 bis dahin und wiedersehen
[Musik]